so plenty of tournaments have been
canceled recently due to the global
pandemic it's just not
safe right now to have a bunch of sweaty
dudes packed into a convention hall
but what if i told you one tournament
said [ __ ] it to health and safety
guidelines and went
ahead with the event anyway and then
tried to cover up the entire thing
one recent cod land said that they were
going online
but footage leaked this past weekend of
players at the event
playing call of duty and that's when
everything exploded
so what happened did the event
organizers lie
did players just not listen to
instructions it's a confusing story that
i tried to get to the bottom
all right guys you know what don't at me
is it's our youtube news show where we
break down the biggest stories from
esports and streaming and if you like
that
i got good news for you we're going even
deeper now on twitch
so tune in every wednesday at 1 pm
eastern for our talk show clouded
and make sure you follow the channel so
you know exactly when we go live
so back on july 31st the american gaming
network was supposed to host the agn
call of duty indianapolis open lan event
it was being promoted as one of the
biggest amateur cod events out there
with a prize pool of 7 500
to be clear this tournament was not a
part of challenger's league which is the
official semi-pro league of cod esports
agn is a party tournament organizer who
according to their website runs
tournaments for call of duty
valeran and rainbow six siege now as you
can imagine with the world in the midst
of a pandemic having a bunch of sweaty
dudes packed into a convention hall
is not the best look so on july 31st
the day the tournament was supposed to
start agn decided to move the tournament
online
quote after discussions with
representatives from activision we are
deciding to change the indianapolis open
to be online only for health and safety
concerns
players are advised to participate in
the tournament from their home location
alone we apologize for any inconvenience
in which this may bring upon players
spectators and organizations we look
forward to working with activision for
future events
end quote this sentiment was repeated on
august 1st by jeffrey elliott who
according to agn's website is the cfo of
the company
and while that sounds like the obvious
and smart thing to do
the tournament allegedly continued as a
lan event later that same day
basically what you just saw looks like
that lan event with a bunch of sweaty
dudes packed into a convention hall
exactly what agn said they didn't want
to happen
on top of that another video surfaced
that looks like a bunch of people
packed into an airbnb trying to continue
playing the tournament online
gage cash a co-founder of agn who has a
name that belongs in mortal kombat
distanced himself from the event and
said that the indie open was to be
played
online period but according to a report
from dexter there were allegedly agn
employees at the event
despite agn saying they had nothing to
do with it
people were even alleging that agn only
put out that original statement to hide
from activision blizzard who are the
publishers of call of duty
the fact that this lan event was still
taking place
now this whole situation caught the
attention of dominique jeleno who's the
general manager for the toronto ultra
a pro call of duty team competing in the
call of duty league
she replied to a tweet with quote i
reported
everything to activision blizzard
absolutely stupid and i can't believe
that
they thought a they'd get away with it
and b be bold enough to post about it
end quote
former mlg event organizer adam apigella
even weighed in calling the situation a
disaster
i also reached out to cash elliott and
multiple sponsors
associated with the tournament cash told
me that the narrative online is full of
lies and isn't true
but didn't explain why that's the case
and
elliott just pointed me to a statement
that agn made after all of this
controversy popped off
quote in order to preserve the
competitive integrity of the online
tournament
we have decided to postpone the second
day of competition
to next sunday august 9th 2020.
due to an overwhelming amount of players
away from home with the inability to
play in a safe environment
we feel that this is the best way to
ensure that everyone is competing
safely and fairly the remainder of the
tournament end quote
also when i went back to gather more
information on the indie open
agn has deleted the page from their
website now even if players
ignored agn and cash's statements that
the tournament had been moved online and
even if agn had nothing to do with this
secret land tournament
the question i have is why did they wait
until the day of the event to move it
online
it's not like the pandemic caught
everybody off guard both the cod league
and the challengers league moved all of
their remaining tournaments online
months ago why couldn't agn do the same
and remember a representative of
activision reached out to agn
which according to their statement is
why they decided to move the tournament
online
and that's a pretty big red flag because
to me what that says is that agn was
fully prepared to host a pretty big lan
event in the middle of a pretty
dangerous public health crisis
and the only reason they didn't is
because activision well
stepped in and told them not to because
let's be honest when you plan to host a
lan event in the middle of a
giant global health crisis you are
putting people in danger
now i have no idea if agn is going to
take disciplinary action against the
players who did show up to this
secret tournament also cash who if you
remember is a co-founder of agn
retweeted somebody comparing the
multiple worldwide human rights protests
with these tournaments
implying that if one is allowed to
happen these tournaments should also be
allowed to happen
and yeah i don't know if that's it chief
if agn knowingly hosted this secret lan
event after saying it was going online
that's [ __ ] up and they put people in
danger and if that's the case
i hope activision blizzard takes action
against these guys
the first like few months of this
pandemic i was [ __ ] all over the
place
like mentally physically i was kind of
lost and
you know recently i feel like i finally
got my footing under me and i'm doing
better
and yeah but i'm still [ __ ] a little
loopy the last
this week has been um [ __ ] insane
short weeks like i said are
just not i don't like them i don't like
them